all right thanks Peter I want to welcome
everyone to today's NCBI minute my name
is Valerie Schneider and I'm a staff
scientist here at NCBI who leads various
teams that are building tools for
sequence visualization and analysis so
in today's session I'll be showing you
how to use one of these tools which is
the variation viewer to do interactive
visualization of NCBI annotations for
variant interpretation I'm going to be
highlighting several tracks in the
browser that are useful for variant
analysis and I'll also show you how to
visualize your own data in the browser
how to identify and assess variants and
illustrate how the browser integrates
with other ncbi resources like clinvar
pubmed and DB snip where you can
continue your variation analyses i'm
going to be using slides today to walk
through these various tasks and the
first slide that you just saw in this
webinar contains a link to these slides
as well as to PDFs and other handouts
that cover this same material so that
you'll be able to walk through these
same steps later at your own pace so
I'll just point out that one of the
easiest ways to get the variation viewer
is at NCBI is via the clinvar homepage
whose URL is down here at the bottom of
the screen alternatively you can go
directly to the variation viewer browser
with the URL that I've got showing down
here so first let's take a look at some
of the features of variation viewer that
we're going to be using today in this
overview slide here I've highlighted the
two main components of variation viewer
the graphical display as well as the
variant table below we'll be using the
graphical display to configure the
tracks that we want to see of interest
and below this variation table provides
information about the variants that are
annotated in the region shown here in
the graphical display and the table can
be filtered according to a variety of
variant characteristics such as the
pathogenicity the allele frequency and
so forth of different variants and as I
briefly mentioned the table and the
graph
will display our interactive such that
if you update the region that's shown in
the graphical display the content of the
table is going to change accordingly
other features that we're going to use
today are the pic assembly tool as
variation viewer supports content from
both grch37 also known as hg19 as well
as grch38 also known as hg 38 we're
going to use the search option to
navigate to regions of interest and
we're also going to use the section over
here called user data and track hubs in
order to add externally sourced data
into this browser so to illustrate the
different types of variant analyses that
you can do in variation viewer I'm going
to use the following hypothetical case
study that's described on this slide
here so you can imagine you're working
with a collaborator who gives you a VCF
file that has three suspect variants
from a patient who's exhibiting a
phenotype suggestive of severe combined
immunodeficiency also known as skid
suggesting that the ad a or adenosine
deaminase gene might be involved and
your collaborator also tells you that
this patient additionally suffers from
irritable bowel disease so today we'll
look at how we can use variation viewer
to evaluate and prioritize these three
variants that your collaborator gave you
and also to see if we can find any
evidence to suggest that the irritable
bowel disease is perhaps associated with
the skid Lake phenotype so next let's go
ahead and get variation viewer set up
for our analyses using the steps that
are outlined on this slide here first
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to select grch38 for our analyses as I
just mentioned previously variation
viewer does support analyses on both
assembly versions but for today in the
interest of time we're going to take the
approach that's described in this case
study here in which our collaborator
made their variant calls on grch37 but
they also provided us with a VCF in
which the results were already remapped
grch38 and which we're going to decide
to make use of in order to make sure
that we're evaluating the variant data
in the context of the updated human
reference
bleahh so next we're going to go ahead
and we're going to select our tracks
taking advantage of a feature known as
the NCBI track sets and the track sets
are pre-selected collections of
high-value tracks that are relevant to
different types of analyses so today
we'll use the genetics and variation
track set which contains genes a track
for all snips as well as several variant
associated tracks here such as snips
that are associated with clinvar records
and also snips that have publications
finally after we set up our tracks we're
going to go ahead and we're going to
upload that VCF file we got from our
collaborator from the options menu here
in the user data and track hubs section
I'm going to click the add files link
and then I'm going to provide an
optional track name which I'm calling in
this case patient variants grch38 and
then once I click upload that track is
uploaded to the browser and you can see
that the features on the corresponding
locations of the variance in that VCF
file are now provided in a table in this
user data and track hub section so it's
updated to give us this table with the
VCF content next I'm just going to go
ahead and enter a DA into that search
box in order to navigate to that genomic
region in the browser just so that I can
get oriented to the display so right
here I've just shown you that graphical
display from variation viewer and what
you can see here with this orange
bracket are the tracks that came from
that genes and variation track set so at
the top here we've got the NCBI
annotation gene annotation and we're
looking at a da where the thin line is
the intron and all these tick marks here
are the exons in the gene now down here
at the bottom highlighted with this
purple bracket you can see the VCF
derived track which we added last and
since I added it last it's at the bottom
of the display so now I can click
and dragged on this track to move it
directly beneath the genes track to
facilitate my analysis and the next few
steps so to navigate to the location of
any of the VCF calls and that file that
we were provided we can click on the
corresponding row in the table in the
user data and track hub section so we're
going to start our analysis today
actually with the second row call equals
G so I click on that and the browser
updates to that location and as I
mentioned our uploaded track has the
green highlight shown here so you can
see how I've now dragged it beneath the
the gains track as I mentioned before
and the thin line here in the genes
track again indicates that we're in the
intron of the a T of an intron in the a
da gene now while most of the other
tracks in our track set here are empty
we do see that there is data in the DB
snip all data track and if we blow this
up we can see that there is a snip rs-24
four zero seven four that's annotated at
the location of our call so to learn
more about this particular snip we're
going to make use of the variant table
down here at the bottom portion of
variation viewer as I mentioned that
table can be filtered by different
characteristics and right now I'm
showing in the table only the snips and
I'm excluding any structural variants
that might have come from the DB bar
database now in agreement with the
graphical display that we just looked at
the table tells us that the snip is
intronic and it also shows us that the
thousand genomes project found that the
associated a allele at this location has
a minor allele frequency of zero so at
this point we're going to go ahead and
remember that our collaborator made
their variant call on the grch37
assembly and we also remember that that
and genome allele frequencies are based
on grch37 so in this case the grch37
reference allele was an A and that's the
allele that had the allele frequency of
zero which is indicative of a possible
assembly area error in this earlier
version of the human reference genome
now I could update variation viewer to
look specifically at the grch37 content
to verify the a at this location but
again that allele frequency suggests
that this is an assembly error so
looking more carefully now at grch38 we
see that the reference assembly now has
a G at this possession which indicates
that there was an assembly update
between the two assembly versions so
based on these data we can conclude that
we're able to actually deep prioritize
this call from our collaborator because
the G that they saw is not actually
variant relative to the current
reference assembly so moving on line we
can use the user data table again to
look at another variant and in this case
we're going to go to the location of
call equals a so we click on that and
this is now the variant that is centered
in our graphical display and if we blow
this view up again here we can see that
once again we have a snip that's
annotated at the position of this call
but this time however a review of that
filtered variant table where I've got
that variant now highlighted in red
shows us that it's an exon ik missense
variant and that our call is also a
minor allele which in this case has a
nonzero allele frequency as determined
by the exact project so if we click here
to expand that row of the table we
actually get additional information
about the affected refseq transcripts
associated with this variant and we also
learn something about the amino acid
changes for the variants that fall in
exonic regions now in addition to
looking at the variant table we can also
notice that the
is content in two of our browser tracks
the clinvar short variations track and
the cited variants track so let's take a
look now at what we can learn from these
two different tracks the clinton of our
short variations track only includes
short variants that are annotated with
clinical significance in clinvar the
color that you see here is used to
represent the most severe packaged in
the city reported with the deeper colors
corresponding to more severe effects
hovering over an annotation in this
track will bring up this tooltip that
provides the variant ID as well as a
link to the relevant clinvar record if
we go ahead and click on that link we
can see that this variation has been
submitted multiple times to clinvar and
it's associated with severe combined
immunodeficiency which is our patients
phenotype so let's look next at the
cited variants track which contains only
variants cited with DD snip ids in their
publications the number in this box
represents the number of published
sniffs overlapping that position
hovering over any of the features in
this track brings up a tooltip that
includes links to the corresponding
abstracts in PubMed so if we click on
the first of these we discover that our
call or our snip is located in a hotspot
mutation or is in a hotspot location for
a DA so these data combined with the
data from the clinvar track and the data
that we saw in the table suggest that
this particular call from our
collaborator is a promising candidate
that we might actually want to pursue
further now in order to understand why
this location might be a hotspot for a
DA mutations we can investigate the gene
annotation at this region in greater
detail so we'll do this by expanding the
gene track display and we can do this by
hovering over the track title which
brings up this menu here with this
tooltip and if we click on this
icon we get the following menu and we're
gonna go ahead and set the display
option to show all and we're going to
make sure that we've clicked this other
setting to activate product features so
once we do that our display updates and
we're going to take a fresh look at this
gene track what we see now is our gene
features in green in purple we have the
transcripts and below in red we have the
CDSs and beneath this in black we have
the features that are projected from
this gene in this case the translations
and annotated domains as well as some
other information now if we hover over
one of these right here we find that our
mutation this we can find here with this
red arrow is located actually very it's
in a metallo hydrolase domain which is
very close to the active site residues
of the protein so this information that
we're getting from the browser is
further confirming for us that this is
really a high-priority variant and a
possible contributor to the observed
skin phenotype in the patient so let's
move on now using the user data table
and navigate to our third candidate call
equals T so once again our display is
updated to put our call in the center of
the graphical display and we can see
that once again we have another intronic
variant and while once again there is a
known sniff annotated at this location
turns out that there's no data in the
clinvar sighted variant or any other
track and this genes in variation track
set to suggest any relevance of this
call to the skidline
phenotype and our collaborators patient
fortunately NCBI has many additional
tracks available so in order to further
investigate this call we're now going to
make use of a new track that's available
from refseq at NCBI known as the
biological regions tract so features in
this biological regions tract include
non-genic functional element
that have been experimentally validated
so in order to get this new track into
the display we're going to click on this
tracks button that's up here at the top
right and we're going to select
configure tracks in the resulting dialog
that opens we're going to go ahead and
click on the Search tab and then we're
just going to start typing in the search
box
biological regions and we'll get some
results back and we're going to go ahead
and select the first result right here
which corresponds to the functional
elements that were included in release
109 which is the latest refseq
annotation of grch38 so then when we go
ahead and click configure this track is
going to get added to the display now
for ease of viewing today I've gone
ahead and already dragged this track up
towards the top of the display just
above our patient call track so here's
our call and here in aqua and red are
the biological region features what we
can now see is that our call is within
sequence that's been annotated as
functionally relevant hovering over any
of these features brings up tooltips
with information in this case we see
that our call overlaps both an enhancer
and a locus control region in AD a the
control expression in the finest the
tooltips also include links to the
relevant abstracts in PubMed where this
experimental evidence came from for this
biological feature so from these results
we're able to conclude that our variant
that our collaborator gave us could
potentially have a functional effect on
a DA expression despite being located in
an intron thus we'd also want to go
ahead and prioritize this variant for
further review so this is information we
can feed back to our collaborator lastly
let's return now to that irritable bowel
disease phenotype that our collaborator
mentioned to us the genetics and
variation and track set that we've been
using also includes a track called gap +
NHGRI Jewess catalog and DB gap
submitted association analysis results
which features the top G wass results
submitted to dbgap + published results
from the NHGRI EOS catalog I'm using
this slider up here at the top of the
graphical display now in order to zoom
in in order to get a better sorry to
zoom out in order to get a look at
whether there are any results in this
track that are near the ad a gene so I'm
going to use the slider to slide back to
the zoomed out position here and when
the display updates in this view here
I've just highlighted for you here in
red the position of the ad a gene and
down here are those three calls that our
collaborator gave us and down here at
the bottom now is that NHGRI gos catalog
track and you can see that there are
actually some hits in this track that
are just down stream of the adn gene so
blowing this up we can take a better
look at the content of this particular
track in this track both the scatterplot
above these bins and the business
themselves reflect individual p-values
so both the color and the dots location
correspond to the p-value and we're also
getting here the count of reported
associations for that snip so if we
hover our mouse over the bin that has
the top hit right here we get a tooltip
that opens up and we see that this
particular snip which I've highlighted
here in red is a result from the GYC
catalog and it reflects an association
with ulcerative colitis and there's a
link down here to cut med so we can get
more information so by looking at the
content in this tooltip and this track
we're able to tell our collaborator that
they might want to follow up on this
particular information to further
evaluate a punitive link between a da
and irritable bowel disease so while
this concludes the very
analyses that we're going to do today in
our webinar I also want to point out
that there are other browser features
that you might find useful in your
analyses first I want to emphasize that
you can share your configure display
with your colleagues by clicking on this
share this page link at the top right a
variation viewer secondly you can save
your track configurations in the display
to your my NCBI account using the my
NCBI track collections option it's here
underneath the tracks menu lastly by
clicking on the Tools menu you can go
ahead and generate printer our
publication quality PDFs of the display
and these are vector graphic images that
you can then update to further modify as
you need so with that we've come to the
end of our case file and our analyses to
look at three variant calls in the ad a
gene using the browser we were able to
discount one of these calls as an
artifact of grch37 assembly error and we
determined that the other two are
candidate snips one being in exonic min
cents variant and the other being an
intron ik variant we also use the
integration a variation viewer with
clinvar and pubmed to get in additional
information about one of the variants
and we used the new biological regions
track to uncover a potentional
functional implication for this intronic
variant
lastly we use the gap plus G waz track
to look for studies that might be
associated with a possible secondary
irritable bowel disease phenotype so you
can use these slides the PDF and the
corresponding a YouTube video that
you'll be able to pick up after this
webinar to walk through these steps at
your own pace we hope you found this
NCBI minute informative and please let
us know if you have any additional
questions about the browser or the data
in the tracks so thank you okay Thank
You Valerie
okay well there don't be any questions
right now so I'll go ahead and in the
webinar and we'll talk to you again soon
thank you for coming